Tú y tus amigos deciden ir a algún lugar pero
no saben adónde; sin embargo, quieren ir a donde
decida la mayoría. Entonces les preguntas adónde
quieren ir, y tu ciudad sólo tiene tres opciones:
pueden ir a un zoológico o pueden ir a un parque
de diversiones -un parque de diversiones con
montañas rusas y otros tipos de atracciones
aterradoras- y tal vez la tercera opción es
ir a un museo. Así que le preguntas a uno de tus
amigos dónde quiere ir y te dice que al zoológico,
y escribes eso; y luego le preguntas al segundo
amigo -que se llama 2- a dónde quiere ir y te dice
que quiere ir al parque de diversiones; en seguida
tu amigo número 3 también dice que quiere ir al
parque de diversiones -le gusta copiar lo que
sea que el amigo número 2 diga-, así que escribes
"Parque de diversiones"; y luego le preguntas al
amigo número 4 a dónde quiere ir y te dice que no
importa, de modo que no sabes qué hacer porque
tenías 3 opciones pero ahora tienes a alguien
que dice que no le importa y escribes eso, bueno
"No importa". Siempre hay amigos que dicen que
no les importa, y luego continúas si tienes, tal
vez, 10 u 11 amigos, sólo escríbelo para todos.
Y una vez que lo hiciste, miras esto y sabes que
quieres decidir algo, quieres decidir a dónde ir
y quieres decidirlo con base en lo que le gusta
a la mayoría de las personas y lo que es popular,
así que primero les haces estas preguntas a tus
amigos y recolectas sus respuestas. Lo que acabas
de hacer aquí es lo que llamamos recolección
de datos, así que sólo conoces los datos
recolectados. Y ¿cuál es la decisión que quieres
tomar? Quieres tomar una decisión sobre dónde ir,
entonces te preguntas si esta es la forma correcta
de mirar los datos, porque quieres saber cuántas
personas dijeron Zoológico: el amigo 1 dijo
Zoológico, el amigo 5 dijo Zoológico. Pero en
realidad no me importa quién haya dicho Zoológico,
sólo quieres saber cuántas personas quieren ir al
Zoológico, cuántas personas quieren ir al Parque
de diversiones, de modo que pueda escribir
Zoológico por aquí y puedo contar el número de
personas que lo dijeron, el número de veces que
aparece el Zoológico, así que aparece una vez,
luego aparece una vez más por aquí, dos veces, he
contado estos dos y veo que ya no hay más. Luego
quiero calcular cuántas personas dijeron Parque de
diversiones, así que escribo Parque de diversiones
y luego voy a contar una persona lo dijo aquí,
uno más lo dijo por aquí, otro más aquí y uno más
aquí, así que ya tengo el Parque de diversiones.
Después voy con el Museo -y déjenme escribir
Museo-, y en este caso sólo una persona quiere ir
al Museo. Y ahora también tenemos esta cosa nueva
que no predije pero está ahí, así que debería
contarlo: la cantidad de personas que dijeron Ni
-que es básicamente una forma corta para decir no
importa-, aquí hay una y otra más, tal vez si
la cantidad de personas que dijeron que no les
importaba fuera el máximo entonces podríamos ir a
donde quisiéramos. Así que el verlo de esta manera
siento que es mucho más fácil tomar mi decisión,
miro esto y no es tan fácil. Así que déjenme
hacerlo más bonito y dibujar un cuadro alrededor.
Ahora se ve bonito y también es más fácil de leer,
así que lo que estoy haciendo aquí es tomar los
datos que recolecté, los hechos que recolecté,
y organizarlos para que sea más fácil leerlos.
Y ahora lo que puedo hacer es comenzar a
interpretarlos, que básicamente significa usarlos
para tomar una decisión o ver lo que está pasando
por aquí. Así que con un ejemplo se volverá más
claro: una de las cosas que puedo interpretar es
que el mayor número de personas quieren ir a un
Parque de diversiones, el parque de diversiones
es el más popular, más popular, o tal vez puedo
decir que el mismo número de personas a las que
no les importa es el mismo que las que quieren
ir al Zoológico, que es 2. Y podemos seguir
haciendo esto, pero todo depende de qué decisión
queremos tomar, y en este caso sólo quiero tomar
una decisión sobre dónde ir y eso se ve bastante
claro: el Parque de diversiones parece ser el
ganador. Así que si tengo que nombrar esto, lo
que hice aquí es lo que llamamos recolectar datos,
preguntar a la gente es una forma de recolectar
datos, pero hay muchas otras maneras. Luego a
lo que hicimos aquí se le llama organizar datos,
organizar lo que acabas de recolectar, que es sólo
otra palabra para poner todo junto de una manera
que sea fácil de leer, y la forma de organizar
los datos depende de las decisiones que queremos
tomar, en este caso queremos decidir a dónde ir,
así que lo organizamos en esta tabla, podemos
hacerlo de muchas otras maneras. Y, finalmente, lo
que hacemos aquí es tomar una decisión o averiguar
el significado, obtener un significado, eso es lo
que llamamos interpretar los datos. Ahora ya
sabes lo que significan estos nombres, y al ir
aprendiendo más sobre los datos surgen formas de
organizarlos, y dentro de todo lo que aprendes
podrás encontrar palabras como pictogramas, que
aprenderás muy pronto, y también aprenderás sobre
gráficas de barras y quizás gráficas en forma de
pastel. Estas últimas son una forma circular de
visualizar u organizar datos, gráficas en forma
de pastel y muchos más. Y todas estas son formas
de organizar datos para que puedas interpretarlos
para un propósito, así que organizarás tus datos
dependiendo del propósito y la decisión que
quieras tomar, tal vez en pictogramas, gráficas
de barras, gráficas en forma de pastel o como sea
que quieras visualizarlos mientras te sea útil.